a new study out this morning reveals
sweepstakes lottery and prize scams cost
Americans millions of dollars each year
the Better Business Bureau calls these
schemes some of the most serious and
pervasive frauds operating today in the
past three years the group says more
than four hundred and sixty thousand
Americans have reported losing more than
three hundred and thirty million dollars
and a Werner shows us how the scams work
and a good morning good morning John
well the Better Business Bureau says
these crooks are professionals they
might take advantage of someone in your
family and they can be very convincing
as they were with one st. Louis man who
believed he had won a chance to pay off
his debts
they said gradual ation mr. Walker you
have to warn the Jamaica swing state
Allen Walker had just moved to st. Louis
in 2015 when the call came in on his
cell phone telling him he'd won ninety
four thousand dollars it would be
delivered soon and all he had to do was
send them a fee for taxes they kept on
telling me oh well you took the wrong
round I he'd be there soon just wait
Walker sent them two checks totaling
fifty five hundred dollars all his
savings they didn't show up with the
prize then he got repeated calls to send
money to different people and that's
when he realized it was a scam
well I really felt kind of HAMP the
inside and ridiculous that I got you
know beat like that Steve Baker is the
lead investigator for the Better
Business Bureau most of the people that
are cold calling you are from either
Jamaica or Costa Rica Baker says nearly
three thousand people reported
sweepstakes and lottery scams to the BBB
scam tracker in 2017 that same year the
FTC and the FBI combined received more
than 145,000 complaints about the scams
losses topped over 100 million dollars
the BVDs study says scammers contact
their victims to get their personal
information every way they can through
cold calling text messages internet
pop-ups the mail and social media like
Facebook the fact that they've really
migrated to social media means there's a
huge new audience that's being
introduced to these Facebook told us in
a statement these scams violate our Paul
we have a dedicated team and automated
systems to help detect and block these
kinds of scams
laker encourages relatives and friends
of older consumers to help them avoid
becoming fraud victims by educating them
if you think you've won a lottery or
sweepstakes and somebody wants money for
taxes or for a third party or for any
other reason they're crooks do not send
money Baker says the actual number of
victims could be up to ten times higher
than actually reported because victims
are often too embarrassed to admit they
were scammed and of course if you think
you're being scammed search the names of
those sweepstakes and those companies on
the Internet look them up because a lot
of times you'll find a bunch of people
who say hey this is a scam really gotta
watch out each time you're asked to send
money though Ana that's always a big tip
up but you get so excited when you hear
but I'm gonna win ninety four thousand
dollars and they just want to believe
believe
think about how cold-blooded the other
person on any of the line is who's
talking to you knowing he's talking you
out of your life savings yeah they don't
care thank you thank you very much